اذ تقول الاسيره الاسرائيليه واسمها مكتوب
على الشاشه المفرج عنها تشين المج
جولدشتاين تقول ان الحراس الفلسطينيين
كانوا يحمونها من نيران الجيش الاسرائيلي
وكنا مهمين جدا بالنسبه لهم تواتر هذه
الشهادات والحاله الجيده التي كان يظهر
فيها اسرى المفرج عنهم ايضا ربما يمثل
ضغطا على الحكومه ايضا هناك خبر عجل اخر
يظهر على شاشتنا الاسيره اسرائليه تقول
كنا نسال الحراس عما اذا كانوا سيقتلوننا
وكان ردهم نموت نحن قبل ان
تموتوا يعني وهناك خبر عاجل ايضا مازال ما
زالت الاخبار تاتي تباعا من هذه الاسيره
جولدشتاين
تقول ان الحراس الذين كانوا يحرسون انا او
الذين اسارون كانوا يحمون باجسادهم من
القصف يعني هذه مجمل شهاده دات تتسق مع
شهادات اخرى لاسرى سابقين جرى الافراج
عنهم وكذلك الحاله الجيده التي ظهروا
عليها وقت الافراج عنهم و يعني هو ربما
تتسق ايضا مع الالتزام الصارم الذي تبديه
حركه حماس بتعاليم الشريعه الاسلاميه التي
تفرض على المقاتلين الاحسان الى الاسرى
الى اي مدن تمثل حرجا بالنسبه للدعايه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه التي تحول شيطنه
فصائل المقاومه الاسرائيليه وتصويرهم على
انهم وحوش
همجيه نعم استاذ محمود اذا نذكر الشهاده
الاولى للاسير المحرره الاولى السيده لشس
السيده الكبيره السن التي تم الافراغ عنها
دون مقابل اذا نذكر ذلك قبل حوالي شهرين
نعم هي حينما خرجت من السجن الرقيب
العسكري لم يتدخل في تصريحاتها التقطتها
الصحافه الاسرائيليه وتحدثت هذه السيده
وحدث وتحدثت يعني عن الظروف التي طبعا
ظروف صعبه في الاسر ولكن عن التعامل
الانساني الاخلاقي الذي تعامله الاسرون مع
الاسيره وبعدها مباشره قام الرقيب العسكري
بمنع اي من هؤلاء المحررين من الاسر
التحدث دون اذن الرقيب العسكري الان في
هذه الايام وفي هذه المظاهره التي تحدثنا
عنها في البدايه في تل ابيب بظهر السبت
هذا كانت هنالك شهاده من السيده التي
ذكرتها اسمها والتي تحدثت عن هذا الامر
انه يعني مدى اخلاقيه الخاطفين بالنسبه
للمخطوفين وكم هي مهمه
بالنسبه للخاطف او الذي اثرها لانها تشكل
بالنسبه له في النهايه يعني برقه تفاوض
هامه جدا يعني هي اساس ولذلك لن يادوها
ولن يسمحوا بقتلها لانه عندها سيخسرون
ولكن ما اردت ان اقوله وا اضيفه لهذه
الليله لهذه الليله من ناحيه المظاهرات
انه بالاضافه لمظاهرات اهالي الاسرى في
تلبيب في الساحه التي اصبح يطلق عليها
ساحه المخطوفين كان هنالك ثلاث او اربع
مظاهرات اخرى واحده في حيفا وواحده في
قيساريا واخرى في تل ابيب وهؤلاء وتلك
المظاهرات الاضافيه ليس فقط لاهالي اسرى
بل لهم ممن يعارضون معارضه تامه الاستمرار
الحرب والحكومه الحاليه وال وهذه
المظاهرات مثلا في كساري امام بيت رئيس
الوزراء امام بيت نتن و في كسريا طالبت
بشكل واضح الاعلانات اللي كانوا اليافطات
التي يرفعوها
اي قالت نتنياهو وال الوصول الى انتخابات
جديده حديثه اخ يعني حتى في ظروف الحرب
هذا تطور هائل مضبوط انه انت تفضلت قبل
كرير في الخبر الذي ادعته بانه الناطق
العسكري اللي وهذه نقطه كنت اود التطرق
اليها معك يعني هذه التصريحات من الاسير
المفرج عنها ربما تعرضها في هذا الوقت بعد
صدور القرار الرقيب العسكري ربما تعرضها
للمسائله المسائله القانونيه اليس
كذلك قد يكون ولكن هي يعني طبعا يعني لا
تستطيع لا يستطيع الرقاب الرقيب العسكري
ان يعني ان يتدخل في امرها في هذه الظروف
لانها يعني قضيه ليست سهله ان ان يقوم
الرقيب العسكري بملاحقته قضائيا ولكن
المهم انه الرقيب العسكري اراد اسكان
هؤلاء الناس وليس فقط هؤلاء الناس والسكات
كل الاخبار التي تتحدث عن الحرب لانه
راينا وكما ذكرت لك في ايام سابقه في ليال
سابقه بانه هنالك في الصحافه الاسرائيليه
بدات تظهر يعني مقالات لم نكن نفها في
اسبوع في قبل اسبوع وهي تنتقد انتقاد
مباشر الحكومه وكذلك تنتقد مسيره الحرب
هذه وذكرت لك اسماء كتاب بارزين
ويعني لهم وزنهم في المجتمع لذلك الرقيب
العسكري حتى لا يتدحرج هذا الامر اكثر
واكثر اصدر تعليماته او كانه يعني ينعش
هذه التعليمات ويجددها خوفا من تاثير هذه
هذا الموضوع على الشارع الاسرائيلي ولكن
على الرغم من ذلك نحن نرى ان الشارع
الاسرائيلي يتظاهر في حيفا في تلافيف في
كيسارا وفي في ايد و ا سؤال عن وزن عن وزن
مثل هذه الشهادات التي تخرج في مظاهرات
كهذه اهي صرخات في بريه ام لها وزنها
ويمكن ان تتناقل داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
وتغير الراي
العام المجتمع الاسرائيلي موجود في حرب
معنى معنى هذا الكلام انه يعني المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ارسل ابنائه الى المعركه الى
الحرب ويخاف انه اذا خرج الى الشارع
ليتظاهر ان يؤثر على نفسيتهم وعلى رو
روحهم المعنويه هذا موجود في كل الحروب
اسرائيل اسرائيل في الماضي يعني اذا ما
درسنا حروب الماضي اسرائيل
كنا نرى انه حتى يخرج الشارع المجتمع الى
الشارع ويتظاهر كان يؤجل ذلك الى بعد
انتهاء الحرب ومن ثم يسقط الحكومه التي
خاضت هذا الحرب هذا معروف ولكن الان على
الرغم انه موجودين في حرب لكن في هنالك
اصوات كثيره بدات تتعالى انا لا اقول انه
يعني دفعه واحده ولكن هذه عباره عن صيروره
معينه بدانا نراها منذ اسبوعين ثلاث
اسابيع والان تشتد اكثر واكثر وكلما كان
موقف الحكومه سلبيا اكثر تجاه صفقه
مخطوفين والاستجابه للشروط التي تفرضها
هذه الصفقه كلما راينا الاصوات اصوات
المعارضه في الشارع الاسرائيلي اكثر تجاه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه يعني هذا في
هنا استجام ما بين القضيتين مع بعضهم
البعض